the internet because now attention is
everything it's in some ways a sped up
version of what the ancient world had
because what will survive is only that
which gains attention and which is able
to keep attention even if it's for a
short time and so inevitably the world
will fall back into tropes of of
attention and memory so if I say that
Trump is brutish but it's complicated
and he has this quality but mostly
negative things I won't get anybody of
attention but if I say Satan then all of
a sudden everybody is listening and so
we end up falling back into ancient
tropes of of mythological patterns but
way faster I mean now it's
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
thank you
hello everyone I am here with Mary
Harrington and I know many of you have
been looking forward to this
conversation we've been kind of skirting
around each other I've been I've been
watching it from the sidelines uh seeing
very many interesting discussions and
her wonderful articles uh but it is a
article called fairy the fairy tale
Allure of conspiracies which really kind
of caught me and I thought would be an
interesting starting point for a
conversation with her and so Mary thanks
for coming on
thank you for having me
and so maybe you can tell us a bit about
what the basic thesis of that article is
and we can start the conversation
because I think it comes close to many
of the things that we talk about in the
symbolic world as well
yeah it's a simple thesis which is that
I mean it's it's what people say about
Alex Jones right that he may be
factually wrong but he's often
directionally right yeah
um or you know to put it in slightly
slightly more kind of highfaluting terms
and without the the extremely
problematic
um commentator what I'm saying is that
when I talk about conspiracy theories or
or the the stories that float around
which tend to get dismissed as
comparative conspiracy theories
is that they made the the factual
details of them can sometimes be way off
and very Baroque but at a metaphorical
level where as a as a poetic level
they're often they're often pretty much
pretty on the nose yeah I think that's
an interesting I think there's
definitely the point to look at and we
can actually use tools of Storytelling
analysis you know you can use the same
kind of tools you use to interpret myths
or interpret fairy tales or religious
stories to look at some of the tropes
that appear in these uh conspiracy
theories you know the the lizard people
one I I like to look at the extreme ones
because I think they're the best cases
you know the lizard people one is is so
simple you know it's the idea that there
are snake people
and that those snake people are not like
us but in some ways they've ended up
becoming our own leaders and so we have
I mean it just basically manifests a
deep distrust in leadership and the idea
that the people that are running us the
people that have control over us do not
want our interests they have other
interests that are strange you know they
have strange interests and not our own
uh I remember thinking much the same
whether there was a whole there was a
rumor I mean it's still flying around
there's a whole series of rumors that
flight that slot around the internet
about her job Joe Biden is not in fact
real some people say he's an AI or that
he's his computer generated simulation
or you know and another variant of this
either slightly more banal variant of
this is the one that just says he's
senile
um I don't know what I don't I mean I
can't I can't attest to the truth or
otherwise of any of these but what they
seem to me to be conveying is a sense
that the the president of the United
States is not in fact the leader of the
United States and the in some sense you
know and the details vary he's uh he
he's a sort of cardboard cutout behind
which Something Is Calling the shots and
that's that's the that that's the story
that's actually being told and the rest
of it is kind of is just kind of
coloration yeah uh yeah and it's story
trolls really and it's kind of falling
into ancient story tropes which are
almost they're necessary to call to the
importance of the of the moment moment
you could say you know I when you look
at the way people tell me like say tell
stories in movies is a good way to
understand that you know in real life
the two the good guy and the bad guy
actually don't fight they don't duke it
out they have armies and they have you
know they have all these bureaucracies
between them and then they have these
massive complicated things that are
really boring to look at and to to think
about but if you want to get the image
of it you have to the two guys the two
protagonists even if they're the
president and some other character they
actually have to physically duke it out
uh or if you want to show a bomb in a
movie you have to have a red blinking
light like no terrorist would ever put a
red blinking light on a bomb but you
have to have that in order to signal to
people what is going on and I think that
in a lot of these kind of crazy wild
imagistic stories you have this similar
type of approach some of the type of
tropes that are being used in in the way
we remember them
right and one of the examples I gave of
these which actually is it
yeah a provocative example I suppose
um concerns the theory which also
sloshes around its kind of Q and on
adjacent I guess that there exists a
conspiracy a sort of baby eating
Satanist conspiracy I mean theories of
that kind have been sloshing around for
some time but there's definitely a cue
adjacent version of that story that
there there exists a cabal of people
who's who are for esoteric possibly
devil worshiping reasons kidnapping and
murdering babies and I'm thinking well
actually this is probably not true
however there is
um there is that there is an
organization that calls itself the
satanic temple and they have created a
Telehealth clinic in New Mexico
um where you can you can obtain abortion
pills in order to circumvent the changes
in legislation since it stops and they
have also launched a court case
um under religious freedom legislation
in the United States to protect the
right to what they call it an abortion
ritual in order to release complicated
feelings around terminating a pregnancy
and I'm thinking this I I mean it's it's
not it's not quite the thing but you can
sort of see how you get from A to B
right yeah yeah and it's also I think
the idea of people who eat your children
is a very important image and it's a
very dark image of course we know how
that it's been used in very dark ways in
the past but it is it is an image which
shows the notion that
something is taking your fruit like
something is taking that which is
important to you someone is stealing it
away from he's kind of pulling it away
from you and and one of the
like one of the one of the important
shifts that in the kind of conspiracy
language or this kind of imagistic
language which is important to notice is
that in the ancient world we used to use
these types of Trope for for the people
that we didn't know who they were right
it's like the cannibals and the monsters
and the lizard people and the you know
the the dog-headed men they're on the
edge of the world right there are these
weird things that we don't know about
these kind of strangers that we don't
know about there's an interesting shift
that happened which is that now these
types of images are used against our own
Elites which is not something to to just
kind of shy to just uh brush away it
seems like there is a shift it means
that
if the normal traditional Society little
tribal Society anywhere in the world
tends to be suspicious of the stranger
now we're suspicious of our own power
the people that are are powerful over us
that's a very that's a different thing
yeah it's a significant shift I mean it
tracks with returning to a more banal
level of interpretation
um it it tracks where the pervasive loss
of trust institutions but you know the
the the explanation for it or rather the
the emotional you you can you can see
you can see where emotionally
um you're re-situating the lizard guys
in in our own Elites rather than outside
on the edge of the world makes sense if
there's been a pervasive loss of trust
in institutions and loss of trust in the
in the alignment of of elites with the
masses and that that's measurably the
case I mean I interviewed Peter turchin
last week who writes about Elite
overproduction and yeah the way the way
in which Elites need to be kept in check
um or at least roughly aligned with with
the masses because otherwise they will
have a tendency to turn power into
goodies for themselves at which at which
point that sets off a whole cycle of
Anita overproduction which usually
accommodates in crisis and some kind of
an uprising at which point the whole
cycle starts again
and in his view I mean I think that is
his phrase was America is now in a
revolutionary situation
um and I think I can't I can't speak for
for where you are that Britain doesn't
feel a million miles off but in in the
Divergence between the interests of
those with the with with any access to
the levels of power and and those those
from whom they're siphoning wealth and
resources and
um opportunities to lead a decent life
so so given this you know the fact that
the fact that that's emanating you know
at the sort of mythical Mythic level as
as lizard people who walk amongst us or
you know baby eating cabals gathering on
Epstein island or whatever whatever
variant of the story we're we're looking
at it doesn't it doesn't feel so strange
really what I find fascinating just kind
of zooming out for a bit is just how
radically and how quickly
um it's become normal again to speak in
Mythic terms since since we transitioned
from from print to a digital culture I
mean this is a this is a kind of long
long term preoccupation of mine the that
transition from print to digital culture
um I I read English literature at
University and I was lucky in in being
probably one of the last
um to get frog March through a prop food
through a fairly a fairly comprehensive
kind of canonical English undergrad in
the sense that my others I mean it was
pretty sketchy but it was it was pretty
much the entire English literary canon
from Beowulf onwards
um and I ended up with in in in order so
you got this that you've got the sense
of historicity and the sense of the
sense of the evolution of ideas and and
tropes and of of literary forms over
time and one of the things I found
incredibly interesting and just has been
preoccupying me ever since is the
transition from pre-modern from from the
pre-modern to the modern moment
um and particularly particularly around
how how stereotypes tropes
um stereotypes and tropes disappear or
become low status at the point of
modernity in a sense yeah the the idea
so what well I can take one word to
illustrate what I mean uh we when we say
commonplace we mean it in a dismissive
sense right but a commonplace in
medieval terms was was something that
you took quite seriously
um like the I forget the Greek term for
it but it's a rhetorical term that
refers to to areas of shared meaning
which are widely understood and which
you can reference if you want to make
rhetorical points in the in in using
using the art of public speaking so the
common places might refer to love or to
the relations between men and women or
to the duties the the obligations of a
prince or the whole series of them and
if you study rhetoric in in the ancient
up to the Medieval World you'd be
expected to have a decent working
knowledge of the common places
um top boy in fact
um
they're a conceptual place but they're
understood as in a sense a very real
place that that people that have that
that's shared and everybody can visit in
a sense it's the Public Square yeah
um but but on the sort of thematic level
and all of that disappears over the
course of modernity to the point where
we had to speak of something being
commonplace is to speak of it being
banal and ordinary and low status and
probably belonging to the peasants it's
boring it has nothing nothing to
recommend it because what we're
interested in now is the signal and not
the noise and and and and common places
are under are just dismissed as noise
rather than being read a signal yeah and
what I find fascinating about the the
having left the the modern era which for
for the digital rather having left the
print era for the digital era is that
all of those top wire back it's just
that we call them memes now
yeah I think it has to do with the
reality of attention that's the way that
I think about it is that the
the ancient world was one in which
attention was extremely valuable because
we had to remember things you know
although we did have writing that
writing was was there were a few books
and a few people had access to them and
so attention and memory are extremely
important and there are certain patterns
of attention and memory which are
pervasive and those you know the the
older they are the more let's say
mythical they are the easier they are to
to to perjure you know and so it's like
if I want you to remember something I
have to be careful not to make it too
idiosyncratic I have to make it you have
to have to contract it in a way that is
as universal as possible and connects as
closely to you as possible that you can
remember it and you can not only
remember it but then pass it down to the
Next Generation Now what written culture
was able to do was in some ways to stilt
that to some degree so you end up with
you know Victor you go in like massive
historically accurate novels that are
that are that are very idiosyncratic and
try to describing all these very little
things but that in some ways is a
it's also in the myth of this kind of
authoritarian publisher and you know
this kind of centralized streamline of
information that peaked with TV like
television was the peak of that you know
where you have this like streamlined of
of a high supposedly high-minded
information that is that is programming
given to us but the internet because now
attention is everything
it's in some ways a sped up version of
what the ancient world had and it's a
sped up Virgin
uh because what will what will survive
is that only that which gains attention
and which is able to keep attention even
if it's for a short time and so
inevitably the world will fall back into
tropes of of attention and memory so if
I say that Trump is is a is is brutish
but it's complicated and he has you know
and he has this quality but mostly
negative things I won't get anybody of
attention but if I say Satan then all of
a sudden everybody is listening you know
uh and so and so we we end it we end
falling we end up falling back into
ancient tropes of a mythological
patterns but way faster I mean now it's
it's set up and it's also being
um
it's being filled in with a lot of the
let's say the
the strange part of that because we
don't have a common place so much we
just have attention so we're just like
cycling attention yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes and no I think there are thorough
magic Landscapes emerging but they but
are very much at the Grassroots and
among subcultures and in in a way yeah
it's moving very fast I mean just going
back to the Trump is citing one of my
informal metrics for whether or not a
political figure gets cut through in the
internet age
um is it could this can could an
utterance by this person ever be sampled
over a base beat and cause the crowd to
go wild and if the answer is no then
they're then they're gonna they're gonna
sleep without Trace
yeah that if someone can't meme it into
the into people's mind I mean you can I
listen and you know I don't I have no I
have no
particular fondness for the orange man
right but pretty much everything he says
it could be sampled over a base pitch
that's right and I don't I don't like
that this is the way the internet that
the the way the way internet attention
works but it but it is and whether
whether we wanted it to or not
um I mean the last British politician
that got sampled for for a rave that was
Boris Johnson which which figures really
um whatever else you may think of Boris
Johnson he was box office
um now that we I mean until somebody
else shows up who's box office in the
same way we're basically in the in the
sink
um but but thinking about I mean you're
saying
um I just wanted to add one thing to
your your theory of attention which I
think is bang on
um it's about it's about what sticks and
what can be remembered because the the
flow of information on the digital
conditions is so fast that unless you
unless something something sticks in a
very catchy way it will just disappear
without trace and I mean most of the
stuff that I write in that sense is
eminently forgettable which I remind
myself of every possible opportunity
um most of my this is why I like to meme
as well as
um as well as theorizing at length
because you often find that that a
coinage a two or three word meme coinage
can unpack into four or five thousand
words or sometimes fifty
um just depending on depending on how
hard you're trying to explain it to
normal people who aren't far too online
for their own good but I wanted to add a
materialist layer to that as well
um being a crypto Marxist that I am
um which is about and the relationship
between meaning making and money which
which is distinct in the print era those
of the the economics of copyright
Printing and relative information
scarcity meant that for a while for
maybe I don't know 250 years it was
actually possible to make your living
directly as a writer and that wasn't
really the case in the Medieval Era
where you might be employed as by the
court as a poet
um or you might be an itinerant Minstrel
or apart from that you probably have to
go join a monastery and copy Bibles and
and find and make your livelihood that
way you know if you're if you want to
enjoy the life of the mind your
opportunities as a sort of independent
opinion have a are pretty limited
um and that and that's true again now um
it's very it's I mean digital multiple
digital reproduction makes it more or
less impossible to make a living
directly as a writer now yeah there are
people who do it but their numbers are
their numbers are pretty low and the
money just isn't that great except for a
handful here and there I mean I think
about Alexander Pope who was one of the
first to nail this is says translations
of Homer in the early 18th century were
insanely successful there was this
incredible incredibly Avid reading
public who were desperate who who maybe
hadn't learned Latin and Greek at
University and were desperate to get
their hands on the on the cultural
goodies and then they flew off the
shelves and you know they they made him
so much money his translations of Homer
that he was able to buy this massive
house in Richmond and you know and
create this incredibly elaborate Garden
there
um it's I mean these These Days these I
don't know people are writing listicles
for BuzzFeed and even they're getting
laid off in favor of church it's a
different world right
um it's a more oral world too it's a
it's a strange it's not exactly oral in
the same way the ancient world was but
it ends up being it's post-literate yeah
the people that are making money with
ideas now are speaking and not writing
so much yeah it's true it's true yeah
it's a it's very very post-literate the
point at which I realized just how just
how far into that we are already was
when I gave a talk at a very a
well-known
very respectable very expensive English
boys school one of the more conservative
of the of the boys schools in private
expensive yada yada yada and one of the
boys came up to me after my talk and
said you should be on Tick Tock Mary
because you you realize people My
Generation just don't read and I'm like
you know this is this is the creme de La
Creme that I'm talking to here this is a
scholarship boy uh one of the most
academically rigorous demanding and
conservative English public schools that
there is and he's telling me that his
job that his peers don't read you know
this is where we we're not in Kansas
anymore yeah yeah and the difficulty of
the oral culture now is that I I want to
be careful not to make too many
comparisons with ancient oral culture
because it it is ancient or a culture
was a culture of memory in the true
scent right it was a cult it was a
culture of internalizing stories
internalizing uh you know places whereas
now it's really it's like it hit
dopamine you know it's still it's like
quick dopamine hit and forget you know
like Tick Tock I mean there's no that
can't be Tick Tock in my house it's just
impossible you know my kids have deleted
all that stuff from their phones it's
insane it's a it's a very dangerous uh
but it it but in terms of let's say
paying attention to culture and noticing
patterns it's still helpful it still
works because it does it does fall into
orality and it does help us see you know
what's going on much it's as if a lot of
the religious things that we're seeing
kind of popping back in have to do with
that as well because certain
you know like ancient worlds would I
don't know what you're going to think
about this but like ancient worlds
talked about you know let's say
transpersonal intelligence this idea of
angels and demons and gods and all the
intelligences would act on people in
like long spans of history and so and so
you know they had this this intuition
that had that they had developed over
Millennia about this and they put they
engage with this you know in the modern
world we were able to dispense with that
completely but now because of sped up
internet attention culture we see back
in the discourse again and we see the
agencies act because it's sped up it
says if you can see you can see like
waves of of control kind of come in and
then vanish right they just come in and
move away and it's yeah yeah
everything's so fast amongst people who
are paying attention it's back in the
discourse again I mean people talk about
agriculturals which is just a you know
that's a that's just a modern kind of
West Coast West Coast America where I
was saying David's right or Angels you
know extra extra payment intelligences
yeah exactly and so yeah or it's close
enough for jazz anyway yeah exactly and
then yeah and then AI is also making us
forcing us to think about this you know
you know I wonder what what as a writer
you know AI is
with how you see it looming on us like
how do you see it affecting your own
your own not maybe your personal career
but let's say writing in general
um I remember wrestling about this and
it's a while ago I might be wrong
um but I think it's gonna I
I think it it will have a sorting effect
um in the sense that work uh
workmen-like
um like jobbing writers will suffer
um and they they will remember there
will continue to be a class of writer
whose work is valued and who stand out
and they'll they'll and they'll do so by
for on two fronts first a capacity for
pattern recognition and sense making
um or rather I mean I mean at the end of
the okay we have to think about what an
AI is at the end of the day it's a
glorified auto correct right it's a very
very clever autocorrect
um that guesses the guess is a guess is
based on based on pre-existing patterns
but it doesn't originate anything it
doesn't actually think
um and it doesn't it doesn't know it
doesn't have any way of sense checking
what its output
um and the difference between that and a
human sense maker is Tiny and also
infinitely infinitely large because at
the end because the a human sense maker
a human sense maker is distinctive on
one on one hand by by virtue of not
having access to all of that information
and all and and also by the being the
being an active awareness which is
choosing which which information to
notice so much information not to notice
in in so so the by the just by virtue of
bit of the that idiosyncrasy
um there's something distinctive about
human sense making
um so that's and
and though there are there are just some
sense makers who are who are valued um
because because their work speaks to
people and that's not something I think
can be that can be reproduced by a
machine so that's that's one thing but
the number of people the number of
people for whom that's the case is is
always is going to be pretty limited so
once once again we're back to court
poets basically yeah and it's also it's
also very difficult to make your yeah
under under conditions where you can
just get a machine to Output text
um jobbing jobbing writing work is you
know a lot of it's just doomed right so
at the end of the day if you do want to
make a living as I said I mean at the
end I think writers will become sense
makers and if you want if you want to
earn a crust as a sense maker chances
are you're not going to be you're not
going to be doing it directly
um it's much more likely I think under
for a host of other reasons as well that
you're going to be effectively a poet
again we're back in we've already exited
the Democratic age and we're back in the
era of Lords and princes
um even if we don't call them that yeah
yeah and it's increasingly clear to me
that survival level as a sense maker
for in for for the most part means some
kind of Court patronage that's just
that's just how things work again once
again you know as James pulos says
digital retrieves the medieval you know
so
um but I think you know in as much as
you did a couple more things on the the
relation between GPT and human sense
makers
um I also think it's possible at least
I'm sort of hopeful that it's possible
that we'll see
we'll see human sense making Thrive to
the extent that it's that it can work
that like I'll start that from Start
From Another another point of view I
think how the way the human sense makers
will be able to distinguish themselves
from the Machine by their grasp of the
tacit but what is not said
um it seems might seem paradoxical to
say that we have writers writers will be
able to distinguish themselves by what
they don't say yeah but but I think but
I mean GPT sucks at puns right
it sucks at implication it sucks at puns
it sucks at illusion because because
there's no thinking there it's a pattern
recognition machine it's just it's just
an autocorrect and so of course it can't
do implication of course it can't do
illusion of course it can't do dog
Whispering so there's an entire entire
Poetics of dog whistling of jokes of
puns of references of illusions of hints
and implications and we're all of all of
which is really to say a literature of
the unstated and
and particularly you know if politics
continues on its current trajectory
towards you know ever more
sensoriousness and restriction I think
those those politics those writers who
are political dissidents or political
radicals will also just be forced to
embrace the Poetics of what's of the
unspoken anyway yeah
um so so I mean those there's some not
particularly well organized Reflections
on how how AIS AI changes writing or
um sense making as a craft but I mean
those that that's where I've got to up
until now I think a lot of writers are
doomed
um I might be one of them I might not
I'm working I'm working on Plan B just
in case yeah but it seems I think that
you're but I think your intuition is
right and it has to do again with I
won't use the word attention in this
case but I'd use the word care
uh you know the I the I AI doesn't care
doesn't have relevance it doesn't it
doesn't have direction right we provide
it we provided direction we ask the
questions we tell it what to talk about
and not only that but we also provide
the intelligence for it that is that
it's the TR the AIS are trained by
humans we have told them what's good and
what's not and that's how they align
their pattern recognition onto our own
right
you can't ask a machine to say show me a
create me an image which is not
disgusting
um and be absolutely certain that it'll
succeed in doing so yeah yeah and so the
so but I think that lines up with your
which was a little surprising to me but
still I think you're right that kind of
new uh feudalism you know in some ways
that what will be necessary for people
as we move now unless very quickly is to
have uh let's say
to have little city-states you know
intellectual city-states of people that
are that are a lot that let's say move
in certain direction but also like you
said have patronage in some ways that
that have
we we also need
how can I say this you know and I say
this because this is you know as you
maybe know like I'm involved in this Arc
thing this this uh and and I I hesitated
a very long time to be involved in that
because I'm not a political person not
you know I'm fine with politics I'm just
not it's not my main thing let's say but
I realized something like what you said
that in some ways we need to be able to
recognize even those that have money
that are that say moving in the right
directions and to be able to to signify
to each other that we're in the same
team let's say and that's a weird it's a
weird thing to have to do uh because it
does signify a kind of fragmentation of
society but in some ways there's no
there's there there aren't I don't see
any other solution at this point
um I mean what the what the implications
are of what was going through my mind as
you were speaking is that some an
unknown at this point is how how that
maps onto existing
exists pre-existing political structures
and pre-existing modes of government
um I guess there's only one way to find
out which is yeah get suckered away get
up and find out
is to do it and see
um but I mean what yeah some I wrote
something else not long ago about how
although as much as it Grieves to me to
think this I think the nation state is
toast I think it's over
um for the very straightforward reason
that there's no Elite consensus for it
it's broadly it's broadly not in the
interests of the of the elite to a
predominantly knowledge workers and very
internationalized both in their culture
and also in their economic interests
to to to support
um band read banded nation states where
where there are clear delineations
between the people here and the people
there it's just it's there's no Elite
consensus in favor of that being the way
of doing things and as far and I and I
don't see I don't see the masses at
present that's having enough leverage to
to push things back the other way unless
something changes significantly
none of them none of this makes me very
happy
um because I'm I'm a I'm a you know I
was raised in the age of
um democracy and I'm a democracy
respecter a democracy enjoyer but yeah
that's that's what I see happening and
and I think it's part it's part and
parcel of the same phenomenons you're
describing about if you like sense
making and meaning making tribes which
are coalescing sometimes around um
singular or or Affiliated sources of of
Finance
of
patronage really
um
you know in a sense as the as the sort
of second order
um layer of cultural production that
relates to whatever this emerging mode
of governance is
um yeah yeah and there is but there's
also In This Moment there's also
possibilities for you know the
crowdfunding possibility has also made
that very interesting you know because
crowdfunding can be a form of resilient
uh patronage if you if you manage it
properly you know the the difficulty of
the ancient form of patronage is that it
was usually single you know like you
said you find a prince you find some
rich powerful person and then and we
need them obviously definitely we need
those people as well but there is also
uh the there is also the possibility of
of uh of crowdfunding which which
makes that a little more uh resilient in
my at least that's what I've noticed
it comes with its own pitfalls I mean
audience capture is a thing yeah if you
want to talk about agriculturals um
there's one you're right no the guru
problem is a real problem like it's a
it's it's a real problem and I think
everyone is trying to figure out a way
to avoid the pitfalls of that of that
issue as we see people kind of fall into
it uh head on and then also become uh
one of the problems with that and you
see that on YouTubers fall into that all
the time is that in some ways
they also they also become a slave to
their own body right they become a slave
to their own aggregor because then they
they just want to make sure they feed
the body what it wants and if that that
can also be low level you know just
constant uh barrage of uh of you know
how can I say this like commenting on
Tick Tock videos which I'm seeing a lot
of conservative people doing now it's
like that's a bad tip of going on a bad
Direction where the where the supposed
Light Social commentators make their
money commenting on Tick Tock videos uh
we're like that is definitely an a
version of audience capture and this
weird this weird uh yeah desire to
please your own your own uh support
group let's say
I hadn't thought of that until you
mention it but as soon as you you said
it I just saw the image in my mind and I
thought yeah that's absolutely that's
absolutely true
um
I wanna I wanna come back to the to some
of the this basic the fairy tale
conspiracy stuff I don't know if you
thought about this one of the things
that I've been thinking about is
you know there's also a weird there's
also this weird thing that that in the
mainstream media which is the use of the
conspiracy theory tag as a political
attack which is as soon as you point to
opposition as soon as you point to
organize opposition if you if you notice
patterns of of of capture and of
opposition in the system then then they
just call you a conspiracy theorist and
people back off right away you know and
so if you talk about the for example
like the the lgbtq thing which is
obviously organized which is obviously
moving which is obviously a politically
weaponized towards certain goals
then they'll say well you're a
conspiracy theorist and it's like and
the and in some ways the the silly
aspect of the conspiracy theories is is
almost advantageous to to that wet to
that type of attack because you can
always move into Q Anon Into The Fringe
Point to the the insane looking
conspiracy and then say well are you
like those people like are you like the
people who believe in the lizard people
as soon as you point to opposition and
so it disarms a lot of these I've
noticed it disarmed a lot of
conservatives especially during covid
you could just see it people were so
disarmed because
you know in Quebec where I am especially
I mean
the conspiracy theorists that the outset
said covet is going to be a tool to
bring about digital ID and and control
people through digital ID and then we
recall conspiracy theorists and when it
happened
there was no way out of it it didn't
matter it didn't matter that it actually
happened and that you know we people
were standing in front of churches with
cell phones you know forcing people to
scan their passport to go into the
church there was no way out of that that
um that trap of being called a
conspiracy theorist and I not sure how
to get out of that trap sometimes Paul
Kingston seems to be doing pretty good
at pretty well at it but it's it's very
difficult to to be able to talk about
opposition and capture without
immediately being afraid of that tag one
of the things Paul does really well
um which which may contribute to this is
he's a good storyteller
um
and when I when I say Storyteller I
don't mean I mean it's very easy to say
oh you know there are there are
mysterious forces which are doing any of
the other um he's you know he talks
about the machine and he talks about he
talks about the things he do I mean
you're familiar with his work
um and he he manages to do so without
imputing it to Shadow to a shadowy other
um and yet making it a very compelling
story which obviously speaks to a lot of
people and I think that's that's one of
the that's one that's one effective tool
um he also uses self-disclosure in his
work which I find which I think is is
significant
um and it's also unusual for a man it's
much rarer in my observation to find to
find men male writers male thinkers who
who are as generous with self-disclosure
as Paul is
um I don't I don't know why that is
that's that's not something I've given
much thought to um but but I mean it's
that this is just my observation it
tends to be a women thing
um but it's I mean I self
self-disclosure Can it can often I don't
know if disarming is exactly the right
word but I think a humanizing effect
which makes it it makes it much more
much more difficult for people who
disagree with you to to dismiss you to
unperson you
if you've already if you've already
drawn people in with your personal story
it's it's much more difficult to do to
dehumanize you out of hand it just is
um and this is I just a few these are
these are scattered I'm sort of thinking
on the hoof here because this is a
really interesting question
um another another instance of somebody
who who uses stories very intelligently
in some quite political some quite
controversial activism it's Katie fast
um who who campaigns for children's
rights in the United States and who I
mean she deliberately avoids standing on
any of the really controversial the
rainbow colored landlines where it comes
to children's rights she's just not
touching that stuff but what her Focus
absolutely laser-like focus on we need
to you know these are what this is what
children need and this is how and and
this is and these are the things that we
need to do in order to meet their needs
and just you know to turn the whole
argument around and to say you know this
this should never be about adult desires
they should be about what children need
um and to that purpose she she has
collected and is as an ongoing project
she collects stories
from people who grew up in situations
where for for reasons for whatever you
know for a sort of different whether
it's divorce or you know being the child
of surrogacy or something like that they
they they had to make a sacrifice for
the sake because of because they're the
adults who in in who cared for them
needed something other than what they
needed
um and and she collects stories and it's
a it's an extraordinary powerful set of
stories to read through and yeah and I
think you know and she she uses she uses
and offers them as a resource to anybody
who wants
who wants something which isn't just
statistics like nobody nobody pays any
attention to statistics right you know
maybe maybe some policy wonks here and
there and you sort of have to you sort
of have to show you have some you like
you need some data but nobody really
listens to data because there's always
other data
um yeah but um
and and then but again in the the sort
of you know Neo neo-medieval uh meme
Plex of the internet people do listen to
stories particularly if they're
arresting stories
um this is this is just they're powerful
currency on the internet so yeah I think
that that's my sort of scatter shot
thought personal disclosure is is a
powerful tool um storytelling generally
if you can if you can draw a narrative
together
which isn't what which doesn't just fall
back on the familiar tropes of you know
lizard yeah the sort of lizard man thing
um and and if you're if and if you can
tell a compelling or or you have
compelling stories from people yeah um
you you can do something you can do
something quite different than you could
if you were just sort of watching to
those guys over there so I think I I
agree and I think especially with Paul I
know his work better and I and I see it
I I see that one of the ways he's been
able to do it is to show the mechanisms
of the machine and to show how they just
are that say they're just Coral areas of
of Enlightenment modernism that this is
just something that plays out you know
like a like a story right it's like
which you put these things into place
and you start the the ball starts to
turn then at some point it reaches this
point like this is where we are but one
of the things that
makes it very difficult at this time is
that there are some people who do
identify their enemy right very clearly
and will say like Western culture is our
enemy basically or however they phrase
it you know like the this or that the
the group our enemy like the
conservatives the right Wingers like to
be for example to be called a right
winger is like everybody shakes like all
the conservatives start to shake when
they're just being called the right
winger and so there's this weird like
imbalance where on the one hand the the
one side is not only allowed to call on
their enemy but does it similar
constantly like just non-stop with all
the weapons possible and then
yeah and then and then and then I need
this is my pre like my maybe this is my
perception and then it's like I realize
that I'm always trying to do the Kung Fu
move like I'm always trying to do the
Jiu Jitsu thing I'm both trying to to to
do this thing where I'm not I'm not
doing that and I'm wondering you know is
it cowardice like is it is it is it
being a good Christian like I'm not sure
sometimes the reasons why I realize that
this is necessary to kind of to try to
do this type of Jiu Jitsu I don't know
I'm I'm also really thinking at the edge
of my thought here when I say these
things no I understand it's a fun enough
I've been writing about exactly this
today
um it's still still a work in progress
so I'm sort of hesitant hesitant to try
and set out the whole thesis
um but my my sort of my working my
working hypothesis is that we end up
doing so much Jiu Jitsu not least
because we've conceded a great deal more
of the frame to to the opponents than to
our opponents than we imagine yeah um
because even conservative have for the
most part
um accepted in principle that normal is
the enemy yeah that the the the
normativity is bad or the normativity is
at the very best at best suspect I mean
actually this in in a funny way this
this articulates with
um the the pre-modern modern modern and
post-modern story of of how how of the
role played by pattern recognition I
mean in in a sense if we're if we're
talking about if we're talking about
means and and meme culture and the meme
Plex one of the reasons the left can't
mean is because they hate normativity
they suck at memes because they're
always in though although they they
never want they're never interested in
paying attention to the noise they never
want to pay attention to the signal and
because that's that's the essence of
what progress is that's the essence of
what the machine that's that's what the
machine runs on the signal rather than
noise
um and mean means a noise you know they
are they're they're aggregate they're
they're aggregate top wire that emerge
out of out of the sort of collective
semi-conscious or subconscious yeah the
the mean Plex the general
um sloshing the here and there of
signification and sort of shared shared
recognition of what the world is and
they're funny because people recognize
them they're funny because and they they
travel to the indirect proportion to how
how
instantly intelligible they are
um
so you know having having said all of
that
um where was I going with this
the the uh oh yes the war on normal and
the war on normativity and the
politicized war on normativity
um essentially we have we have to be
able to defend the meme we have to be
able to speak from the place to the meme
does that make sense yeah yeah
so by that time and we have to we have
to see the entirety of the discourse
which even even a great many of us have
largely accepted as a as a as a normal
phobia as a bigoted hatred of what's of
what is in fact normal and observable
and and in holy you know self-evidently
intelligible to the vast majority of
people and and I think I'm coming to
think that it's it's time to go on the
offensive against nomophobia yeah and
and to see it to see it as as a kind of
bigoted irrational fear of and and
attempt to destroy something which is a
a fundamentally fundamentally culturally
and socially important and be
um just impossible to destroy anyway
it's futile it's futile and socially
destructive to to try and to try and
abolish all Norms in favor of personal
freedom it's just profoundly wrong thing
to do whether it's the you it's the
Revolutionary Trope which is which has
been there now for a very long time
right it's been there since the
enlightenment at least you know this
vision of Revolution as being
as being the justification for narrative
and and so you know like every movie
that I grew up with had that Trope every
single one always had the Underdog Story
and the Underdog Story it's not wrong in
itself it's fine the Underdog Story is
fine but usually the way it is presented
as the ragtag weirdos who basically take
power from the established thing and
that structure is just basic our basic
narrative structure uh and so it's
difficult because conservatives also
have that same basic structure and and
so that what are they conserving I don't
even know like I use the word conserve
myself but I use word conservative but I
really don't see myself as a
conservative because I don't know what
the hell they can serve anymore right
it's like in some ways
this is this is why I prefer reactionary
yeah
there's a wonderful quote from Nicolas
Gomez Davila he says the true reaction
is not a Seeker after abolished pasts
but a hunter of sacred shades on the
Eternal Hills and I'm like yeah sign me
up
but it's an interesting sacred shades on
the Eternal Hills it's good it's an
interesting time to be to be so I don't
know you probably probably don't know
about this but you know I decided
very similar to what you're saying that
in some ways there was this strange
moment right now and in storytelling
where all of a sudden the normal can
become
bright and precious and and desired and
so we're publishing these series of
fairy tales right I'm doing a version of
Snow White and it's Snow White I don't
know what to tell you it's snow white
there's no there's no deconstruction
there's no cynicism there's no like
weird it's no way it's it's I I hope
it's a very insightful version of so
white I hope it's a it's a version of
Snow White that that will actually bring
people into understanding the reason and
the purpose for these ancient stories uh
but it's Snow White and you know what we
we started crowdfunding it a week ago
and we're like 200 000 in and it's we
still have like three weeks ago and
people are just like raving and and just
and people throwing massive amounts of
money at this because I think I think in
some ways that's that's where we are you
know Disney is going to put out a
version of Snow White next year uh and I
don't know how they can even do it I
don't know how they can do it how they
can't even have snow white get being
woken up by the prince it's not even
they're obliged to mess around with it
just what are they going to do with that
yeah you just know they're going to ruin
it because they because they they're
contract they're obliged by virtually
obliged to destroy it that they have to
destroy Snow White they have to they
have to rape Snow White that's all your
Disney is is obliged to to rape Snow
White so it can't it can't go any other
way because that that's just where they
sit up typically in the story but here's
the thing I mean you know if I say you
know we we've we've left we've left
modernity which is to say the print here
and we've arrived somewhere new you know
post-modernity or digital culture or the
cyborgater or whatever you want to call
it which has retrieved the Memphis from
just being commonplace in the
disparaging sense and returned it to the
common places in in the much more
powerful and historic hysteric sense
possibly at full you know if if along
with that we're getting Neo feudalism
and we're getting a return of artistic
patronage
um it's it's just possible that we might
we might also get a return of normal as
something which is no longer disparaged
and
um no longer abject and low status I
mean that's been the direction of travel
for a great many decades if not
centuries you know to to disparaging the
normal as something something that at
best taken for granted if not actively
actively uh the enemy of all that's good
and Progressive
um I I think I think the tide can and
will turn I mean maybe I'm over
optimistic and I'm usually wildly out on
the timelines for all I know this won't
happen in my lifetime but but I think I
I think I think that I just I think the
tide will turn because there just aren't
any left but anything else yeah I'm a
long-term Optimist short-term pessimist
that's for sure and long-term optimists
because in any case you know just
because we've lost a normative language
we're talking about human nature doesn't
mean our Nature has gone away exactly
you know it's yeah well that's just what
will happen is that that nature will
appear suffering for some time you know
because you can't we can suffer
uh perversion and Distortion of our
nature we can suffer it and we will and
so that suffering is a call it's always
a call and at some point that call
I think I think what sits at the root
what's it to the at the behind that call
and what really or gives it power which
I already see giving it power is the
fact that the ultimate the the ones the
the group that ultimately pays the price
of the war on normal is children yeah
um because the children's Children's
maturation on organismic needs have not
changed just because the desires are
lots have changed that's just obviously
true you know a baby still needs what a
baby needs and a child still needs what
a child needs you know of course human
cultures are infinitely malleable but
there's a baseline right that just
hasn't changed and isn't likely to
change anytime soon and I mean if you
were to genetically engineer a baby not
to not to need or not to need its
mother's love it just wouldn't be a
person I don't know what it would be but
it wouldn't be a human being
when we get to the point where we're
where we're Waging War on normal to the
extent of asking oh you know um
commercial surrogacy for example this
isn't this is one I come back to again
because it's so fundamentally at war
with with what and it's such is such a
transparent instance of putting placing
on a baby's shoulders you know the the
sacrifices required to meet adult desire
it's it's so clearly what's going on
there you're asking a child to sacrifice
mother the bond the bond with his with
his or her mother you know gestational
mother you know in order to in in order
to meet the needs of an adult
um which is which is radically inverts
the way the way it ought to be in the
caregiving obligations that adults owe
to Children
um and but but I think that that
essential principle stands actually for
most of the wars on normal you know the
where where the war on normal it hits
hits the buffers hits a immutable limit
in human nature yeah the the group that
pays the price is always children
yeah and I think enough people see that
there are great many France you know I'm
not going to point at them because I
imagine you can you it doesn't take very
much reflection to see to see fronts
where people are saying no enough you
know leave leave the kids alone yeah
that's that's happening on a great many
fronts at the moment and I probably
don't need to point to them
um I I think that's yeah people see it
and people say no enough you know enough
we've asked too much of children and
it's we need to we need to turn we need
to turn things around a bit yeah well I
I hope so I hope so the machine is
strong right now let's just say uh and
it's getting stronger next year is going
to be
it's going to be a great year for the
for the machine the world seems to work
the feet of the world seem to be
something like the American election
cycle like that seems to be how the how
things happen and so we have to be we
have to be attentive to next year and
see you know how to say how things play
out in terms of all these questions
they're going to accelerate quite a bit
and with AI with these with AIS battling
each other uh it's going to be a wild
year that's for sure yeah it is
right yeah America sneezes and the rest
of the world catches a cold you know it
remains it Remains the global hegemon
it's all it's the Run of our day you
know where where it is in the sort of
Rome historic cycle is I think more more
knowledgeable classicists than me need
to argue that one
I don't think that that one's that was
actually not that hard to notice it's
interesting I don't know I think some
people think but it's it's still in the
Republican stage I'm not so sure yeah
yeah I think yeah well yeah whatever if
it the let's say the emperor is not it's
not it's not visible yet you know at
least it is in Star Wars using Star Wars
terms it's the you know Palpatine is
still in the in the in the corner like
he's still kind of hiding out you know
we'll see if palpatitude I think one one
not not at all impossible hypothesis is
that we end up mapping radical
egalitarianism onto the need for an
American Caesar and the only possible
solution is to put AI in charge yeah
because they're the only the only way to
to not set any other any any one person
over another is to is to hand off hand
off responsibility and accountability to
a machine yeah and the willingness of
people to do something like that is just
so surprising to me and I've noticed it
my daughter yesterday got from her from
the the Quebec government she was asked
as a student to to participate in a poll
and the and the poor this is from the
government itself and the poll was
asking students what they thought of
having AI counselors for a student with
emotional problems
yeah
because you know no Prejudice come on if
it's an AI it has no none of the none of
the it has no Prejudice it has none of
the Hang-Ups not all the all the the
hate that humans have you know the the
implicit biases it's crazy I mean the
the fact that the government that my
government is willing to ask a 15 year
old that you know send her an email and
promise her fifty dollars if she
answered me that you could win fifty
dollars if she answers that poll is
completely insane like it just shows
where we are
yeah there's a I'm I'm gonna have to go
in a minute so we might have to it's up
another timer but there's a there's
another piece in here that the puzzle
the the kind of big the big narrative
from pre-modernity to modernity to
post-modernity which is about about and
and and how that relates to storytelling
and fairy tales and and that that's how
we conceive ourselves yeah which is
which is something which which in tandem
with the you know I mean
with the the rise of literacy
um changes and becomes something
something much more into I'm sure you've
read Walter Walter on I mean when we're
talking about orality and literacy yeah
and the the transition from morality to
literacy you know comes comes with uh
transition in how people think of what
and understand their interiority in a
much more General sense and this is you
know more and more erudite and
intelligent people than me have have
drawn links between that and the
emergence of the individual as such you
know as a feature of the modern era and
then the political systems to to meet
and to meet and engage with those
individuals it stands to reason that
that that's changing again in fact I see
it changing already and where this
relates to the idea of having an AI
counselor is because I I sometimes want
I wonder what you think of this it's
occurred to me on occasions that that
the the postmodern understanding of
selfhood or if you like the digital age
understanding of what a self is is much
emptier than the print era one it's much
more it's it's a little more it's less
like a it's less it's less like a deep
pool or a place than it is like a dream
catcher it's something through which
things flow under which things can be
hung it's not it's not a it's not a
place in which things are collected so
much and and I wonder if from that
perspective there might not be a great
many 15 year olds who've just
internalized from a young age that
understanding of selfhood and just don't
really have a problem with being being
catechized by a robot because they don't
think of their inner lives as being that
different to a glorified autocorrect
yeah what do you think that's a good no
I think that's a good Insight that's a
good insight and I think that
all of the all of the like for example
like the even the fact that you know
we're moving to more and more towards
medication as solution to all kind of
mental health problems you know like
this is the the basic key shows us that
the idea of the self as something that
you nurture is something that you that
you you have to align with virtue all of
these types of things it would used to
be a normal thing to think about the
self are are are are slipping you know
and we see as a we see the human as a
kind of as a complicated machine that
you have to press the right buttons and
so it's like if I if the eye can press
the right buttons it's like of course
then the eye can just press those
buttons and then you'll be fixed if we
can give you some pills and you give you
pills and you're fixed and so there
isn't I would say you're right that the
I mean the self the idea of the Soul
obviously in this was the ancient idea
of the Soul uh is very
um yeah it's not as strong now and the
the uh the idea fluid identity is very
popular like the notion the only place
the only place where we see the soul
alive and well of course is in gender
identity
yeah but it's it's it there's a there's
a move towards
fragmentation and fluidity is the best
way to talk about that like it's so so
there's this weird Mo Rel relationship
between pride and fluidity which is a
which is almost like a it's almost like
a contradiction you could say because
usually you're proud in something right
I don't know I think there was there was
there was one one very famous figure
from myth and Legend who was both proud
and resistant to all boundaries who who
Springs to mind
who is it
uh he's he's kind of he's kind of the
bad guy the bad guy in most stories okay
yeah that's fine I get it yeah no that's
right that's right well that's all yeah
that seems to be victoriously
notoriously associated with those of
those things all right okay we cannot if
we we end without saying his name that's
probably a good place to end our
conversation yeah yeah don't don't don't
do that
practice attention
for Mary thinks that it's great first
conversation I I really appreciate it
it's been such a pleasure I'm sorry it's
been I'm sorry it's so short but I have
to go I have to go pick up my daughter
no worries and so hopefully at some
point we can do this in person you know
all right great thank you